and I'm really looking forward to the
nays answer on this one how do you
handle pressure from family members for
example there's a lot that's be unpacked
in this question here for example
pressure to buy a safer / newer car just
for the baby yes these are the same
parents that had a 10 year old vehicle
when they had us yes suddenly the choice
is reckless and unsafe for me I think
their heart is in the same place as
yours and that they want your kids to
grow and to thrive and to be happy and
healthy and successful and and
remembering that and reconciling this
idea that your goals are the same but
it's a matter of how are you going to
get there right and how what is the path
going to look like to get to those goals
and I think that always reminding
ourselves that they're not trying to
control you they're not trying to make
decisions for you but they really do
want what's best for you I think when it
comes to extended family members and
moving towards simplicity and
intentional living that we have to make
the decision for ourselves that is this
going to be part of our core values that
we're going to be passing on to our own
children and if it is it's something
that we need to learn to stand up for
just like I mean in our in our family
our core values as you know we don't do
drugs right so I want my kids to know
that and when they grow up I want them
to be able to stand up for that right
and my family we don't do drugs so and
it's sort of the same idea that you're
taking if they see you standing up for
what's important to you and standing up
for your values they're going to be able
to do that as they grow so by saying by
you know just kind of swipe it down to
the rug and like oh it's okay like it's
fine and not talking not having those
hard conversations I feel like we're
also showing our kids that some of the
values we're trying to instill in them
aren't as quite as concrete as we want
them to be yeah it's I would ask to like
is this a symptom of something bigger
that's going on because if it's just
well hey Kathy if your parents want to
buy you a new safer car let them buy you
a new car but but I mean is it is this a
symptom of them looking at like oh they
need a safe car is there other things
that that you have control over that
they also view as being unsafe because
the cars
seriously it might just be a symptom
what they're seeing something much
greater but I agree with you if the
parents are instilling safety into the
children doing everything they can
except for yeah they can't afford to buy
afford to buy a new car then yes like
eventually the parents parents should be
able to see oh yes like you are
instilling safety in these kids you are
worried about these kids so yeah I guess
instill safety wherever else you can to
show your parents that you are indeed
concerned about your children's safety
I can't nerf the world though no
absolutely not and I think that's the
the other side of it in fact I think
we've gone way too far as a society in
fact this is something that backs and I
are often we are on the edges of well
yeah Ella is almost 6 let her go out by
herself it's fine but because my
worldview is when I was 6 like I did
nothing but go out by myself because my
mom's drunk on the couch and so like I
was a latchkey kid at age 6 and it was
not a problem now there's probably
comfortable in between my situation and
the well we're gonna put you in a padded
room with a straitjacket on so you can't
hurt yourself it's there there's
somewhere in between them we have to
find that in-between but then also we
have to sort of test the limits one last
thing from rob bell here we're talking
about communicating he said the goal is
to keep your kid talking when your kid
confides in you that builds trust it's a
it's as if they're saying can so so one
of the things we often do is we say like
well because I said so right that
doesn't build trust your if your kid
comes to you with a problem that's as if
they're saying can you mom dad can you
be trusted with this thing that is
troubling to me that is intimate this
deep problem can I trust you with this
I'm testing you by asking you these
these deep questions and as a parent you
can either add to their burden or you
can help your child carry it and
sometimes I think unfortunately we
unintentionally add to the burden of our
children
and I think when we look at behaviors
like lying and withholding information
it's often because they're afraid of our
response so if our children are afraid
of how we're going to respond to
whatever it is in their life that
they're struggling with or a decision
that they've made or behavior that
they're not proud of if they're afraid
to bring that to us or if they're lying
about it it may in fact be related to
our response to those behaviors in the
past and knowing that we are someone to
be feared rather than someone to be
trusted and sort of how do we find the
balance and that
you